trying to like threaten to me these are
like the people from military side they
said like girls if you if you come back
to Myanmar you're definitely sure in
jail or something like that they're
trying to uh threaten to me you know but
I never give a vet and I never step back
because I think like I'm doing the right
thing so they cannot threaten to me but
they're trying to tread on social media
and also they go to my home influenza
they have a really really great power
they have so many fans they can share
like what is really happening in Myanmar
right so the military trying to focus do
the influencers start sharing
information to International Community
so I think that's why they decide to try
to cut through all the influenza fast
and to detain in the jail you know in
Myanmar Now is really really like
tolerable situation even you go out they
check your phone the soldier are on the
street they check your phone if they see
you share on your social media something
about the military they detain you to
the gym it's it's crazy situation